oh my God okay the ending of this story
is crazy I kind of can't wait to get to
it because I feel like you guys are
gonna freak Bud uh yeah so we're
covering Defenders Beyond right we
basically finished Avengers versus X-Men
versus eternals now we need a new series
to start so uh here's the thing all
right let's just kind of get into this
right so what ends up going on here is
this takes place after the death of
Stephen's strength right if you guys
remember that story that we covered
Stephen Strange is dead in Marvel Comics
and his role was basically taken over by
CLIA who was at one point his Apprentice
then she became his girlfriend then his
wife and then they got a divorce and
they've kind of been basically Friends
with Benefits ever since and so she's
like the new Doctor Strange Stephen
Strange is out but what ends up
happening here is one of the things that
Stephen Strange had done is he had kind
of left these instances where he had
kind of foreseen these events unfolding
different things that were going to take
place over the course of the universe
and kind of left a portion of himself
Beyond I mean if we're being honest here
it's a plot device right it's one of the
things you got to notice about this uh
Story by Al Ewing he really really has
fun with it more so than anything else
which is kind of the best way to handle
this kind of stuff but what is going on
here is Stephen Strange basically visits
blue Marvel Adam Brashear and this is a
cool moment because this is something
that you don't really see all that often
right when it comes to Adam Brashear the
blue Marvel and Marvel Comics he's
always one of these characters where
he's kind of fringed to a degree you
don't see him all that often but when
you do it's usually because something's
popping off like in the Doctor Doom solo
series when Adam Brashear the blue
Marvel fights Doctor Doom and yes we are
going to cover that because that story
is amazing
it is like the best Doctor Doom story
ever but what goes on here is you
basically have Adam Brashear in his
underwater base right those of you guys
who are unfamiliar with him his base of
operations is actually down in the ocean
it kind of allows them to basically
operate in peace and he's met by what is
in effect the spirit of Stephen Strange
that basically starts presenting him
tarot cards with the intention of
basically bringing back the Defenders
now it wasn't always that way in Marvel
Comics right the idea of like the tarot
cards and the Defenders that didn't
become a thing until the 1990s the
original Defenders team was kind of a
loose knit coming together of
superheroes for a particular purpose and
that was supposed to be it it became so
popular that Marvel actually kept it as
an on running series that went on for a
long time the Defenders was immensely
popular when it was running in Marvel
now over time the series became
unpopular because basically writers you
know different writers just kind of
screwed it up but in the 2000s Marvel
tried to bring it back and what they
gave us was Doctor Strange's secret
Defenders and so what Doctor Strange
would do is that when there was some
kind of a Calamity say for example like
dormammu was coming back or something
like that he would just start drawing
tarot cards and he would assemble a team
he was an amazing concept that was
terribly executed Doctor Strange would
assemble a team that had like Wolverine
and Spider-Man and like Cyclops and
somebody else I'm just arbitrarily
drawing names here but he would
literally just assemble a team of
characters that you would never expect
expect to see team up and they would go
face a villain that you would never
expect to see them face off against it
was great and I absolutely loved it but
the thing about this is that this is
where all that comes from and so hitting
up Adam Brashear there are a few things
that Adam Brashear takes note of for
example
eternity mask right The Eternity mask is
a really cool concept of Marvel Comics
the way this works is that the wearer of
The Eternity mask immediately has a
level of power that matches whoever
they're facing off against so if like
some random dude named Chris who's
literally just walking down the street
stumbles Across The Eternity mask he
could put it on and then if he were to
fight like World breaker Hulk he would
immediately have as much power as World
breaker Hulk has that would actually
change based on how powerful the the
world breaker Hulk becomes if he faced
off against Galactus he would
immediately be as powerful as Galactus
it really is it's kind of a McGuffin in
comics but it is cool it's a really
really interesting thing but immediately
one of the things to know is that Adam
Brashear is a man of science so when
he's met by this kind of disembodied
spear spirit in the form of an orb from
Stephen Strange that's like hey blue
Marvel I need you for a magical Mission
his immediate response is like no that's
ridiculous I'm not going off on some
magic Mission because uh because of a
mystical orb told me so but the reason
why Doctor Strange is approaching blue
Marvel is because the threat they're
dealing with doesn't necessarily exist
within the Multiverse itself it actually
exists beyond the Multiverse beyond the
Multiverse hint hint nudge nudge told
you this story was going to be amazing
so here's what goes on right so
literally what what Doctor Strange says
is because of the various things that
you faced off against right the first
Cosmos which we'll we'll cover all that
stuff as we get further on into this
because all that comes back man right
the first firmament the aspirins the
celestials it all gets Revisited here
this story is fantastic God I love this
story so much but he says like you face
off against some of the most powerful
beings in existence right Auntie man
Connor Sims who basically just like
demolished The Avengers and when I say
demolished I mean that doesn't even
begin to tell it right like literally
this guy just ko'd the Avengers like the
most powerful Avengers the century Carol
Danvers kind of which is important I
guess she doesn't really matter but like
basically like he ko'd pretty much all
the Heavy Hitters of the Avengers Auntie
man was on a whole different level and
then he became the like the herald of
Galactus which amped his power up even
more the guy could enter and leave the
Multiverse at will it was crazy how
powerful Connor Sims became but like
Adam brochure's face off against some
major guys and that's why he's here
right that's why Steven strange
approaches him but again a lot of this
is is really just kind of Adam Brashear
blowing it all off and considering it to
be ridiculous until he looks back at the
deck of tarot cards and realizes a card
has been flipped over Beyond his will
meaning he didn't do it somebody did and
the card seemed to have flipped on its
own and the reality is that it basically
shows the dead body of America Chavez
now the reason why this matters is
because when Al Ewing was writing the
ultra ultimate America Chavez was on
that team if you guys never saw if you
if you never read the ultimates we
covered that I'll have the playlist down
in the description make sure you go
check that out at the end of this video
because the ultimate is phenomenal to
give you guys perspective in the first
story arc of the ultimates the team
right so like basically blue Marvel
black panther America Chavez Spectrum
Monica Rambo Carol Danvers America like
they all overpower Galactus in the first
Arc it's kinda nuts it's just it's
ridiculous it only gets more insane from
there like the molecule man comes back
who's ridiculously opius it's a
phenomenal story but the thing about
this is that you end up having him come
into this realization that there really
is more going on here which is really
crazy because America Chavez pops up
just at that point in time now one of
the things going on here is that America
Chavez's Powers aren't really what they
used to be meaning she can't really jump
through realities the way she was able
to before that was covered in America
Chavez made in the USA we're not going
to come over that because that story
sucks but uh that's basically what goes
on there right like her powers are
basically diminished and so as a result
of that she literally hits up Adam
Brashear for health and Adam Brashear
sends her away because realizing what's
going on with like these tarot cards and
magical prophecies that if America
Chavez stays with Adam Brashear she's
gonna end up dying but the truth about
this is that once the once these events
are set in motion meaning once the cards
are drawn there's no way to undo it
right like everything is going to happen
now and that's when Adam Brashear starts
looking through the cards and starts
seeing Loki he starts seeing Taya which
is kind of crazy and Loki and Taya both
show up right now Loki for the most part
is a little bit of a Nuance here we'll
explain him here in a second what's
going on with Taya is she's basically
the mother of Galactus that happened
during the events of the first Defenders
run we can cover it if you're interested
because I feel like some of you guys are
kind of like wait what the mother of
Galactus yeah like galactus's Mom right
she basically joins up with the
Defenders it's kind of interesting it's
a little wonky it's a really really cool
story we we just hadn't really covered
it for this version of Loki this is
actually a Time displaced Loki and it
goes back to the events of Secret Wars
so for those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with that story before Secret
Wars actually happened when Jonathan
Hickman was writing Avengers The New
Avengers Marvel actually had a series of
other stories going at the same time
which was called last days and it was
basically here's what's going on with
different superheroes or different
characters in the universe and like the
days and weeks leading up to like the
end of the Multiverse the collapse of
everything and like this start of Secret
Wars for the character of Loki that he
was accompanied by a chick named Verity
she's not really important here but the
character of Loki what had happened is
that following the events of of Siege on
Asgard when the Loki that we had always
known had basically been killed that
that version of Loki was reborn as what
was basically the god of stories instead
of the god of Lies he did have his own
set of events that were going on
honestly that was probably the coolest
version of Loki that we'd ever seen in
Marvel Comics he was literally going on
missions to make up for all of his ask
Miss Deeds which was cool and so what
ended up happening is that during the
last day's event Loki ended up leaving
and going outside the Multiverse and
then once the last day's story arc ended
in agents of Asgard he basically opened
a door to see what came next now the
intention at that point in time is it
was basically him skipping everything it
was basically Loki saying okay he's
skipping past Secret Wars opening the
door and then going into the reborn
Multiverse what arguing did as part of
Defenders is he said actually before
Loki showed up after Secret Wars was
over he basically left he ended up you
know going back to the universe that
came before and that's how Loki's here
right that's why Loki's here at the
moment so it's really kind of a detour
right so like you're in California
you're driving down to Florida to Disney
World instead of going straight to
Disney World you stop and you go to
Texas for whatever reason makes sense to
nobody but yourself because who the hell
would want to go there but you stop in
Texas for a little bit that's what this
is right it's the equivalent of Loki
making a side stop in Texas and so with
this team basically assembled because
everybody's here that every read that
like literally the entire mission is
kind of etched in stone like there's no
way to undo this now right like they're
literally charted on this course and a
series of events outside of their
control are going to start happening
that will force them here and so as a
result of that one of the first things
that pops off is basically the portal to
the neutral zone ends up going awry now
the way the neutral zone has been
handled in Marvel Comics has shifted
over the years so one of the things to
know and I believe we covered this but
I'm not 100 sure that one of the things
we found out is that when it came to the
blue Marvel he actually had a son named
Kevin he actually had two sons one named
Max and one named Kevin but his son
Kevin had basically been sucked inside
the neutral zone and there was no real
conceivable means of getting him out and
so at that point in time the way the
neutral zone was established in Marvel
Comics is that it was a place outside
the Multiverse but led to what was
basically the Omniverse right so a
collection of multiverses and really it
was just an Uncharted place an Uncharted
realm we didn't really know anything
about it we just knew that it was a
place where matter and antimatter
coalesced the hypothesis among fans is
that because Kevin Brashear exists in
that realm if he's able to return to the
main Marvel Universe and simultaneously
use all the power that he's accumulated
or that has kind of infused with his
body while he was in the neutral zone
he'd be the most powerful force to ever
exist in the history of Marvel Comics
like everybody would fall before him his
power would dwarf everyone right
literally every character you've ever
seen or heard of in Marvel regardless of
the level of power they have up to and
presumably including the one above all
would be dwarfed by the power of Kevin
Brashear because at the end of the day
the one above all is the one who created
the entirety of the Multiverse what
happens when you're a being who's
powerful enough to basically leave the
purview of the one above all and achieve
a level of power that exceeds that of
the one above all but again that's all
just a fan Theory there's been nothing
to solidify that but what is going on
here is the neutral zone is basically a
place kind of an intro remediary right
so you leave the Multiverse you go into
the neutral zone and then from the
neutral zone you can go into anywhere
beyond the Multiverse and so that's
really what they're looking at here the
kicker to all this is that with them
being sucked into the portal the first
thing to come across or the first being
they encounter is eternity and Eternity
literally tells them okay like you guys
are basically in liminal space at the
moment meaning you're within the
universe itself but you're transitioning
beyond the universe you know I can
essentially allow you to pass because
the threat that you're facing off
against exceeds anything that can
basically thwart it within the universe
right like you have to pass through me
to get there and I'm going to let you
because this threat's bad enough you
guys need to deal with it and so as a
result of that they pass through
eternity they exit the universe and they
end up basically in what lies beyond the
Multiverse initially all they encounter
is darkness and it's really Adam
Brashear kind of giving us this
explanation and saying that like
everything's gone right there is nothing
there they're passing through all these
different things now this mess with a
method of Passage where you're seeing
them going through what's basically
Darkness this is another instance where
things shift right so for example when
the far Shore was introduced in Marvel
Comics which is basically where Cosmic
entities go to die that the method of
transporting there that that was one of
those instances where you literally had
like transluminal space so you would see
like just these these bright lights and
all kinds of different stuff passing by
you and so on and so forth it was
literally just kind of a combination of
all kinds of crazy things right it's
just bright lights and shapes and just
sort of indiscernible stuff and so
having Darkness here is just another way
to show the same process but just
showing it in the form of Darkness it's
a little weird it's a little wonky but
it is a cool thing but what goes on is
that as Adam Brashear literally gives us
this explanation right he's like I don't
know exactly what's happening here I
can't even see anything so I don't even
know where we are right we're literally
flying through what is in effect space
and time and then eventually moving
beyond it and so he's like is it
happening now is it happening then it's
really more him just kind of talking
into himself to a degree and he even
goes as far as to say like we're moving
faster and faster and then we're going
faster yet again the void of nothing
flips on an invisible axis where
crossing a threshold coming in for a
landing then there's a voice in the
darkness if I were a younger man I'd
think it was the voice of God but I've
been around for a minute I know better
than that I know it's trouble and the
voice simply says I am from Beyond
that's right ladies and gentlemen this
that's right ladies and gentlemen yes
ladies and gentlemen the beyonder has
returned and here's the thing it's not
even just the beyonder who's returned
we'll find out in the next video that we
do it's the beyond durs the race of
beyonders are back in Marvel Comics and
for those of you guys who were
unfamiliar with this the last time we
saw the beyonders they killed the
Multiverse so God only knows what's
gonna happen next but I will say this
you think blue Marvel's been powerful so
far you haven't seen anything yet
because this guy gets you a whole new
level of power that just defines the
word broken with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
we'll be back next week with more
Defenders Beyond on Tuesday and I will
catch you all later
peace